before i turn it over to governor
sisilak and state superintendent of
instruction
joan ebert i wanted to provide a few
general coven 19 vaccine updates
as you may have seen this morning the
dhhs
office of analytics made some important
updates to our vaccination dashboard
that can be found on the nv health
response website
the coveted 19 vaccination page has been
updated with additional data points to
include race
and ethnicity information the dashboard
will also be updated on mondays
wednesdays and fridays moving forward we
know this is important information for
the public
and appreciate the work of the office of
analytics to continue
to improve the dashboard i also wanted
to talk briefly
about the ongoing work the state is
engaging in with local health
authorities
and jurisdictions as it relates to
equity in vaccine distribution
as you know the team will provide
updates to the coven 19 mitigation
and management task force on a
consistent basis
but i wanted to provide a brief update
on what we've done so far
we are currently working closely with
clark county to provide additional
support to reach this shared goal
we appreciate their partnership thus far
and while we are currently
very involved with clark we continue to
support equitable distribution with
every nevada county we understand the
challenges
our seniors facing and are facing and
we're developing
opportunities to serve nevada seniors
who may be homebound or have mobility
barriers
we have suggested mobile strike teams to
meet these residents where they are
and we are able to gain additional
guidance from the centers for disease
control
and prevention about transporting
punctured vials
in order in order to support this
delivery mechanism
also the addition of the statewide call
center has enabled those eligible for
vaccination
but who may be experiencing a barrier
for internet access
to receive information and assistance
over the telephone
the call center is able to utilize
multiple languages
which supports equitable access to
information
we are making gains every day and i am
really proud of the partnerships we have
and the dedication of those
in the field to make every effort to
support an equitable distribution
we will continue to evaluate progress
and use the nevada
vaccine equity collaborative run by
immunized nevada
that will have its first meeting next
week to help inform
vaccinators on tailored messaging and
outreach
as well as community-based support
across the state
by those who work within equity
day-to-day
as wraith as race and ethnicity data is
received and then published
we will support counties in providing
context to the data
while evaluating outreach efforts and
any challenges experienced to address
vaccine confidence
or access issues earlier this week
we mentioned that some vaccine
deliveries may be delayed in arriving
this week
due to severe storms across the country
our team is continuing to monitor this
closely
and we are working with health districts
and pharmacies that may be affected
we ask nevadans to continue to be
patient at this time
as some events will need to be
rescheduled
doses of vaccine are allocated on a
weekly basis
and we encourage nevadans to go to
nvcobidfighter.org
for appointment availability at this
time
i will turn it over to governor sisselok
who has additional exciting updates
about our vaccine efforts
good afternoon thank you to caleb and
candace for letting superintendent joan
ebert
and i join you this afternoon to provide
a few important updates
and thank you candace and your team for
continuing to work with federal and
local partners
to help manage nevada's vaccination
efforts
while keeping an eye on equity i want to
start by providing some other important
updates to our state vaccination program
we know that kovit 19 continues to
impact older events
at higher rates and i'm pleased to
announce
that beginning next week more of these
nevadans will be eligible for the
vaccine
some of nevada's counties have already
started vaccinating those 65 and over
but some of our larger colleagues have
not beginning next week
the state will be opening immunization
opportunities to nevada's
65 and older through the federal
pharmacy partnership
program in all counties we were able to
do this because of the increases in
allocation of vaccines
to these pharmacy programs from the
biden harris administration
i am grateful to the administration for
continuing to work collaboratively
with states to ensure we are increasing
the supply of vaccinations available
due to continued limited allocations and
the shipments of the vaccines
only the pharmacy partners enrolled in
the federal pharmacy partnership program
will be offering vaccine vaccines for
those 65 plus beginning next week
unless your county has already begun
vaccinating those 65 and older
in the community these pharmacy partners
will begin to schedule these
appointments next week
after shipments of the copa vaccine are
received
this is great news but i know everyone
is eager to expand
to 65 and older across the state and all
vaccination sites
that's why it is my hope there's a goal
i've set for the state team
that we can work with counties who have
not yet been able to offer the vaccines
of this age group
to ensure they can expand vaccination
events statewide
for the 65 and older population by march
1st
again some of our small counties have
already been able to offer vaccines to
those 65 and older
but this effort will help some of our
larger counties move into this category
faster
while we welcome the news that federal
pharmacy program has been allocated
in the increasing doses from the federal
government compared to the first week of
the program
we know it will not be enough to cover
the range of the values of this atrium
we continue to ask nevada to be patient
as we await increased allocations from
the federal government
so again if you are 65 and older
or have a loved one who is 65 and older
opportunities will be available to
schedule an appointment
and one of nevada's pharmacy partners
beginning next week
envy coven nvkovidfighter.org will have
additional information
on how and where to schedule those
appointments the veterans who do not
have reliable internet access
who need help to reach out to the
statewide call center
at 1-800-40
that's 1-800-401-0946
additionally i wanted to provide some
important updates related to nevada
schools and high school sports as you
all know
getting students back into classrooms as
safely as possible
is one of the top priorities that i laid
out in my state of the state address
last month
this afternoon after this call my office
will be releasing a new emergency
directive
and related guidance documents that will
provide county school districts
the flexibility to help bring more
students back in the classroom safely
but the reality is that in order to get
our students back in the classroom and
keep them there
it's going to take every nevadan to make
these students a priority
we know from the cdc that reopening
schools can be done safely
when community communities implement and
strictly adhere
to proven mitigation measures our
translucent rates are on the decline
in order to continue getting more
children back to in-person learning
is critical that all nevada's do all
they can to help keep the rates
low when you make the safe choices to
practice social distancing
and wear a mask and washing your hands
you're doing it for our kids our
educators
and our families before i turn it over
to superintendent ebert i have one more
announcement
that will impact nevada students and i
know they've been waiting for this
as you all know up until today full
contact sports have been prohibited
i know this has been difficult for many
of our student athletes and their
families across the state
we've been working hard to develop a
plan for how we can allow these athletic
activities while still keeping our
students and adults as safe as possible
i'm excited to announce today that under
this new emergency directive
full contact sports regulated and
governed by the nevada interstellar
activities association the niaa
they resume practicing competitions if
social distancing and all move
requirements can be better
in order to allow niaa regulated full
contact sports to take place
the niaa must develop a mandatory
covert 19 testing and mitigation plan
that then must be adopted and followed
by each school district and school
intended
to allow full contact sports a plan must
require at a minimum
weekly testing of coaches staff and
athletes participating in these sports
prior to the start of the full contact
sport competitions between schools
the local school districts or palm
school superintendent
must approve the commencement of the
particular full-contact sport
including agreement to implement the
niaaa testing and mitigation plan
spectators will be allowed to attend all
nia sporting events subject to the
applicable
limitations set forth in the recent
gathering directive
host schools will be responsible for
ensuring compliance with
applicable gathering and event
guidelines
capacity limitations and protocols
resumption of full-contact sports only
applies to those regulated and governed
by the niaa full-contact sports
games and competitions remain prohibited
for travel and club leagues
private leagues artistic sports programs
and similar
non-niaa sports leagues at this time
we are taking the step of allowing full
contact sports to resume competitions
for niaa only because they are able to
be highly regulated and overseen by our
school districts
including the regular testing
requirements on may 1st
2021 we hope to transfer these decisions
to local authorities
as a reminder all other non-contact
and minimal contact sports including
baseball and soccer
have been allowed to hold practices and
competitions
since october last week we allowed
tournaments for all of these
allowed sports beginning march 15th
there will be full guidance sent shortly
after this press conference
i will now turn it over to
superintendent joan eber to discuss the
new education directive
more in depth thank you
good afternoon everyone thank you
governor sislek for putting education on
our children first
i'm really excited that the new
directive will allow school districts
who have already been offering
in-person instruction to some or all of
their students for at least 20 days
the new directive will allow them to
increase the occupancy
capacity to 75 percent or
a maximum of 255 250 people
in a contained space while maintaining
other safety measures
such as mandatory mass and social
distancing
we will also be increasing the capacity
limits on our school buses to 66 percent
again with mask requirements and social
distancing in place
this will make sure that the difference
that we're doing
and the many things that all of our
school districts are
participating in and transporting our
children
two-in-person instruction is at the top
of mind
i want to take a moment to recognize and
thank our district superintendents our
school leaders
educators professional staff the
students and your families
for all of the amazing work and the
perseverance through this challenging
time
thank you to our communities working
together to prioritize health and safety
i especially want to note
our partners in dhhs the social
emotional supports for
our students and staff we can continue
this movement
to get all of our children back into our
classrooms
making sure they have equitable access
to high quality learning opportunities
each and every day it's been
an amazing ride as we've been
through all of this and i want to thank
the community for bringing these numbers
down so that our children
can have in-person learning we have
our largest school district 320 000
students on march 1st
who will be going back pk 3
going back into in-person learning by
choice
parents are allowed to make those
choices whether it's in person or at a
distance
and the other 16 school districts have
had that choice since school has opened
and their
work has been phenomenal but i
call upon all of our community members
as the governor has to continue
keeping these safety measures in place
so that our students can participate
in in-person learning we have over half
a million children in our state that we
serve
and we want to make sure that they're on
a path
to success and that they're engaged with
their teachers in in-person learning
thank you governor i know we have some
questions coming up and the staff will
be managing those
thank you superintendent ebert sorry
governor
thank you superintendent either governor
sislak and candace for providing those
updates
we will now move into a short q and a
today i see lots of folks are already
raising their hands so i appreciate you
all doing that
we'll start with sam metz from the ap so
sam if you'd like to
unmute and then you can ask your
question
hi governor thank you so much for doing
this on my question
so administration officials and federal
agencies like the cdc
have said that vaccines for teachers
shouldn't be a prerequisite for
reopening
to keep it as a simple yes no do you
agree
and if we're letting conventions malls
and restaurants accept hundreds more
people in march
is it a problem if clark county doesn't
come up with a more concrete plan to
return fourth grade and above to
classrooms
well it's my hope and i'll let joan
respond as well it's my hope that we can
get
uh more kids in classrooms as quickly as
possible
i feel it's extremely important it's not
just a yes or no answer
i know that they have allocated or given
the states this responsibility i think
it's important that teachers have
vaccines available for them
we have made it available to the
teachers i hope they take advantage of
that
and i hope that we can get through get
four through 12
in the classrooms quickly
thank you governor yes um so 16 of the
17 school districts as well as the state
public charter school authority have had
our
educators in classrooms since august
and so what's wonderful about this time
is that we do have the vaccines
we continue to learn and move forward
and get our children back into
face-to-face learning
i just want to add there uh sam that
superintendent ebert has done a
remarkable job
and then 16 of the 17 counties were way
ahead
of the 17th county which is clark which
is the biggest one
we're hoping that clark can catch up
quickly and we can get these kids all
back in the classrooms
thank you governor thanks sam thank you
superintendent ebert i had david from
channel 8 as the next hand that i saw
thank you and thank you governor for
taking our questions today
today uh nevada ranks again near last
on the distribution on the vaccine and
the number of arms that this
vaccine has gone into in terms of state
population
i know this is something you've been
talking about been working on with the
white house
and on top of that we had news today
from the southern nevada health district
that the weather has delayed shipment of
the modern
vaccine so they're only offering second
doses next week
so i was hoping you could provide some
information about your
uh contacts with the white house or the
body administration and the cec on
ramping up getting doses in i know you
had said a couple weeks ago i
i have the people we just need the doses
and then also
talking a bit about these delays and how
it's affecting now getting this next
group
of people eligible thank you thank you
governor i don't know if you want to let
candace maybe answer that question
sure can this could start and i'll wrap
it up at the time
yeah thank you governor so um yeah thank
you david for the question
um i'll address the weather first you
know unfortunately that's something
that's just out of our control and so
we are supporting um as much
communication that comes from the cdc as
possible
in terms of when that will happen and
immediately get that information to our
partners
who will then be able to really support
those rescheduling
appointments for those in you know
across the state
um in terms of our allocation and what
we've been able to administer
um every single county has done a
tremendous job
of actually administering the doses that
they've received
um that's incredibly high they've done
such a phenomenal job
scaling up being able to really use the
doses that they receive
um within a week's time so um you know
outside of looking at the um the rate
per 100 000 i have to say that the
actual capacity of these partners is
tremendous and they're doing a wonderful
job
at actually vaccinating individuals in
this state
you know i'd just like to add that we're
continuing to expand
the uh folks that are eligible for the
vaccine that's why we're going
to 65 plus next week and march first for
all the folks even not the
pharma pharmacy partners but we are i
was on the phone with the white house uh
test was yesterday we are continuing to
ask for more doses
and we're getting the vaccines that we
get into people's eyes
the health districts are doing a good
job they've already said that they've
got problems with people that are
you know double uh booking appointments
so people that don't show up and whatnot
but
no vaccines are going to waste we're
getting put in people's eyes
thank you candace thank you governor and
thank you david for the question i have
megan messerly as the next question on
the list
megan thanks again for doing this
uh this is probably a question for
candice but according to the cdc's
website
walmart is the only retail pharmacy
chain that's participating in the
federal retail pharmacy partnership
program in nevada
one is that correct and two if so my
correction understanding that means that
those 65 and up will only be able to
start receiving vaccines at a walmart
next week
unless of course their county's already
begun to vaccinate that population
and then there's a third question is
someone able to cross
county lines to drive to a walmart if
they don't have a walmart in their
county
thank you megan this is candice mcdaniel
so um we are actually supporting
um and and with some of the state
allocation on top of what the federal
retail pharmacy allocation is so right
now we still have this
um this bridge program that i know i've
we've talked about previously where we
are sharing some of the state allocation
with some of our pharmacy partners um
but then
this additional um federal allocation on
top of our state allocation
is going to walmart um so to support you
know the
exciting news that the governor was able
to just provide about the 65 and older
um all of the pharmacies will be able to
provide vaccination for the 65 and older
population
beginning next week um in terms of
the um you know the county lines i think
that it's
um we've done our best so even if there
is not a walmart in a county um we have
with the help of the board of pharmacy
have actually been able to approach
other pharmacies within those counties
who can also be providers so even though
it may not be a walmart
and we have done our best with the board
of pharmacy to provide that pharmacy
route
in every county so they will also be
included
thank you megan thank you candace we'll
go to um bert bert if you could identify
yourself and what what outlet you're
with please
yes of course and thank you uh for
taking my question this is burke johnson
with nevada
public radio and i wanted to ask about
the county level demographic data as to
who's been receiving vaccinations i see
on the state
dashboard that it appears to only have
demographic info
for statewide vaccinations
and just curious if there are plans
moving forward
to disaggregate that into the individual
counties
and a second part to my question is the
equity initiative that was announced
earlier this month specifically
referenced
clark county and southern nevada health
district will that be expanded
is there a need to expand that to other
counties in the state
thank you bert um so um yeah so the
county level um distribution
if you actually use the the dashboard
that's on the nevada health response
website you will able to
you're able to actually dive into some
county if you just click on those
particular counties
and you'll you'll be able to dive into
some of the deeper data specific to that
county
um in terms of the equity um yes we we
definitely are working very closely with
clark county but
we are continuing to have and reinforce
and support a lot of that equity
um conversation capacity practice with
all of our counties
so um it's not that our other counties
are not working towards this they
absolutely are and we just know that the
majority of our population is in clark
county and so
we're really just supporting a lot of
their data needs at this point
thanks for the question thank you
candace um i have a few folks from rj
we'll start with
jason ort who i believe is a sports
reporter from the rj if you're able to
unmute yourself and ask a question
all right thanks for taking my question
um and this is for anybody who would
like to answer um
obviously high school football is is a
season that's
coming up very soon and i guess today's
announcement removes it from the
the uh from the band i guess on on uh
full contact sports so
just how was that able to happen now you
know what were some of the key metrics
that you were looking at there to make
sure
um that it could be played safely we're
looking at you know the drop in the
positivity rate the drop in the number
of cases
uh a lot of the kids and i fully
understand they want to get back on the
field they want to get practicing they
want to have their games
some of these students are hoping for
scholarships to move on to college
we're going in the right direction and
we decided that it was time now it's up
to the local districts
clark county i don't know if they're
going to participate that'll be up to
them
but there's been a lot of demand in the
in washoe and the rural counties to
to allow us to go forward
thank you
sorry thank you governor thanks jason
for that question we'll go to mary hines
the health reporter from the rj next
thank you and good afternoon supplies of
vaccine remain limited
what is your estimate of how many people
across the state
in the age group 65 to 69
will be able to get the vaccine on a
weekly basis
and how long do you believe it will take
to get everyone in this age
group vaccinated who wishes to be
vaccinated
thanks mary candice would you like to
start with that question absolutely
thank you mary i know that we've talked
about you know the difficulty
in trying to project how quickly or the
pace of which
we are able to get through a particular
population
um you know very very much varies from
county to county
um you know what their throughput
capacity is etc i think that it's also
as we've sort of seen um over the last
couple of weeks um
you know we we do really hope that you
know in the future we
are just only increasing that allocation
that would be able to get from the
federal government so
um if we continue to see an increased
allocation i think that we'll be able to
provide these opportunities to that age
group um
you know as we move through so you know
as we've mentioned before it's really
difficult
to sort of put a timeline on that but i
think it's very encouraging
to see that uh you know the federal
government and the the
vitamin administration has really
supported trying to increase the
allocation
for all states but it's really important
hearing about it really helps us
support just an increase in in access
um so unfortunately it's really
difficult to give you an exact timeline
we do have some good things on the
horizon megan if i could
uh the johnson johnson vaccine hopefully
will be coming forward in the near
future
but darren was approved to put 14 doses
in their violence now
which should help uh the finishing field
aspect of that
get more doses shipped out to the
various states so there are good things
on the horizon
and as candace said we'll just have to
wait and see how quickly
uh we can get our supply our allocation
increase
thank you governor thanks candace thanks
for the question we'll do orco
and then michael scott and then we'll
probably pull to a close for today and
we can circle back with anyone we don't
get to
heather governor thank you so much for
uh taking our questions uh
first i just wanted to ask with the niaa
regulated sports when it comes to
that weekly testing and mitigation that
you had talked about how exactly is that
going to be
monitored and i guess what kind of
system is in place for that
so if i may governor i know that niaa
will be promulgating some regulations
and guidance around this so
um oracle you'll be able to find some
more information um
once that happens but governor if you
have anything to add before we go to the
next question on that one no
yeah it's my hope and our desire as a
state to get these kids back on the
fields
but in a safe manner and our team came
up with some protocols that i think are
very reasonable
be helpful to everybody the weekly
testing and the
social distancing the mitigation
protocols
and in conjunction with uh joan and the
niaa
and the parents and the kids they want
this to work too i think everybody's on
the same page
so i'm confident that we're going to
come up with a plan that'll be
very beneficial for all
thank you and um i'm sorry
superintendent eber were you trying to
speak earlier and i cut you off i
apologize
no i think the you know so yes i guess i
will add uh to what the governor said
the niaa regulations will come out but
it's important to note
uh that the dhhs
the department of education niaa
everyone has come together to make sure
that
the proper testing is in place so that
these students
have access to um athletics and and it's
been
a real team effort um to get this
launched to make sure we can move
in this positive direction um and so i
would look for that
um specific guidance and your question
will be coming out shortly
thank you superintendent ever and we'll
close with michael scott from the rj
and we will loop back on any of the
hands that are still raised
um after we're done here so scott you
can take the last uh bite at the apple
thank you and good afternoon everyone um
candace i i believe this
question would be best directed to you
but anyone is
is open to answer it or chime in if
they'd like
um so nevada is currently working to
roll out a statewide
vaccine appointment system through
salesforce and i just had a
three quick questions about that first
would be
is this going to be this new statewide
system will it be mandatory
for local governments to switch over to
the system since we've seen them using
different municipalities using their own
systems is going to be mandatory for
everyone to move into this unified
system
second what does the state think the
benefits of a unified system will hold
versus the
current uh multitude of systems we have
in place currently
and then finally um i've heard some
concerns from local government officials
about
um that they haven't had a chance to see
the salesforce system yet
see how it operates and the amount of
training time that they'll have with
it before being asked to implement it it
is not very long
and i just kind of want your thoughts on
that is this a system that you believe
that they'll be able to pick up
extremely quickly and be able to hit the
ground running with in a matter of days
or just a week or so
there are a lot of questions in there
candace do you want to try to answer a
little bit there before we
make and this is julia i can take that
too if you want
yeah yeah please go ahead julie okay so
julie peak also dhhs
uh it is a voluntary system the state
purchased it and can be used by anyone
our initial rollout is going to be in
clark county we're going to provide more
details on that starting next week
the benefits to such a system we're
doing a lot of project management on our
end to make sure that it is rolled out
timely it has a good deal of oversight
we can provide
training opportunities and train the
trainer opportunities
um and so our team is doing a lot at
dhhs
for that the benefits of the system as
well is that our call center
will be able to book and change and
cancel appointments really easily
they're getting trained on that system
and will be ready for go live
in the coming weeks um as far as
to see how it operates prior to using it
our team throughout the covid response i
have to call out our it specialists have
been
moving at the speed of light we wanted
to get this tool up before march and our
team has done that
we'll certainly be making changes as we
move along
um with the system but there is uh we
also had feedback from the locals that
they don't want to get trained on a
system and implement a month later
because all of us
have challenges uh remembering how to
use the system after a month so we are
doing
uh training opportunities a few days
prior uh to the launch and then again
we'll have uh
training opportunities throughout
implementation thanks megan
thank you thanks julia and thank you
everyone for joining us today
um i think there were a couple folks
that maybe we didn't get questions and
so if you want to circle back with me
we'll try to help
answer those we'll also as the governor
said have additional guidance coming
forward
so thank you all for joining us today
have a great rest of your afternoon and
we'll talk to you all soon